hey folks happy Wednesday or Sunday or
whichever day it is you're watching this
I figure instead of spending days
engineering the perfect 15-minute video
script while I could be spending time
with my family I'm just going to spend
five minutes shamelessly riffing on a
concept brought up in my comment section
that being slot compression the idea of
slot compression is basically this you
can fit more stuff into your deck more
things of each category like finishers
or Draw or removal if you pick out and
play cards they do multiple things for
Mid vange decks an easy way to do
compression is to run decently sted
creatures that do other things your deck
wants to do in a dirt cheap Rose deck I
built a while back the creature count is
decently high but the vast majority of
creatures in the deck either draw me
cards or make my opponents discard cards
even among the more finisher oriented
creatures that don't fit into these two
categories most are blood Iris effects
which still perform a secondary duty of
discouraging board wipes so the
compression is still there my gly deck
is a more High curved example of this
principle fun fact if you pay a lot of
Mana for a creature it will often be
great for multiple things my deck Cashes
in a hefty 20 or so slots up front for
ramp but it is rewarded for this with a
creature base consisting of powerful
removal and draw spells stapled to five
fivs and 88s and 101s which means that
the deck ends up being able to win games
without a single dedicated wicon slot
another example of this is hate Bears
decks by running Stacks effects that are
also creatures these decks are able to
heavily oppress their opponent's game
plans while still having a board state
to block and pressure life totals
sometimes this pressure will be pivotal
to winning such as in my liasa deck and
other times it will serve more as an
alternative wincon or as hate toward
life pay but regardless this flexibility
is very useful for more combo oriented
decks one way to have plenty of space
for both pieces and supporting cards is
to pick cards that do both if you need a
sack outlet for your combo you'll
naturally run into the issue that some
games you won't draw one and other games
you'll draw multiple you could run only
a couple and some tutors but you could
also run a bunch of Alters in a deck
with some artifact synergies or sack
Outlets that get buff if you want an
alternative Beatdown wion or cards like
fanatical devotion and greater good
which might just be generically good
cards in some decks there are also combo
decks looking for a lot of certain types
of cards to go off such as with a midow
Nila deck there a reasonable plan might
be throwing in lowcost worriers you like
from any color which will further the
beats and combo potential offered by the
commander while also letting you have
high quality creatures the general G
here is that if you can make cards
needed for your combo be also valuable
in their own right in the deck the combo
will feel much less space gobbling this
logic also applies for heavily
synergistic decks if you have a deck
focusing on a particular card type such
as equipments or auras having a lot of
your supporting cards also fit into
those types means that your windc cons
will pack a ton of power and it will
also have the added benefit that
conditional tutors will give you access
to a good portion of your deck the same
goes for decks that focus on a
particular creature type or particular
attributes if you're building a goreclaw
deck and your deck's draw and removal
mostly consists of creatures with power
four or greater suddenly you can fit a
whole lot more beef into the deck while
still having it feel smooth and
well-rounded finally let's talk lands
mdfc utility lands and other dual mode
cards that get you lands are great and I
highly encourage using these I sometimes
see people run land counts in the low
30s in Decks that aren't that low curved
and while I appreciate the desire to
draw gas I Echo interesting failures
thinking here at least do your fut
yourself a favor and throw in some mdfc
or utility lands to bring your count up
to 35 or 36 this goes for high curved
decks running 36 lands as well don't be
afraid to mdfc your way up to 38 or 39
or even break into the 40s ooh I plan to
do a longer video about lands and Mana
bases sometime soon so I'll save further
discussion of the subject until then but
long story short lands are good and
people often don't play enough of them
in casual EDH I've discussed some
different ways to compact your slots you
know to run cards to satisfy multiple
things your deck wants and I think a
logical question to ask regarding this
is exactly how valuable is it to have
compacted slots I like to think I've
laid out a decent case for doing such a
thing you can run more of each
supporting card type while still
maintaining a solid cord to your deck
and you can run a higher land count for
purposes of not getting screwed while
mitigating some of the downsides of Mana
flood however an important thing to
remember is this at its core your deck
still needs to do a thing that wins in
the past I've sometimes Fallen deep into
the hole of synergy and support cards
and built a deck that runs very smoothly
and feels good at the table but
ultimately lacks substantive wincons and
usually just succumbs to getting
outscaled by somebody else I advocate
for people to put more support cards in
their decks because I think the average
EDH player is on the opposite end of the
snappy to smooth Spectrum as me but it's
good to keep in the back of your head
that playing smoothly and having
interaction isn't a substitute for
having a good way to end the game you
should try to have both of these things
in your
deck